I love this story a homeland security
secretary Kristen Nielsen was shouted
out of a Mexican restaurant last night
by protesters who were confronting her
over the separation from parents and the
internment camps of children I don't
know how else to say it it's the
separation and the internment of the
children that the people were protesting
and the story is exponentially better
because it was a Mexican restaurant
although in reality the facts of the
story aren't drastically different
whether it's a Mexican restaurant or an
Italian restaurant or a French French
restaurant all three of those types of
restaurants relied disproportionately on
immigrants from Latin America but
there's something about it being a
Mexican restaurant that makes it that
much better for me and it was a
restaurant called MX DC cocina mexicana
in Washington DC and one person wrote to
me saying that they went to a Mexican
restaurant specifically to trigger
protests the idea that this was some
well thought out idea from Kristen
Nielsen and her staff to go to a Mexican
restaurant to trigger protests so that
then they could maybe try to say we
agree with the emotions expressed by the
protesters or something like that I
don't think it's that well thought out
and we have video Nielsen seems to keep
her eyes down on her phone while the
protesting is going on shouts of shame
and if kids don't eat in peace you don't
eat in peace and it was all captured on
video check it out
[Music]
tens of thousands of people who come
here seeking asylum in the United States
separation imagine trying to deal with
that when you just want your tableside
guacamole right I mean what disrespect
and Nielsen's spokesperson tweeted after
the incident while having a work dinner
tonight the secretary and her staff
heard from a small group of protesters
who share her concern with our current
immigration laws that have created a
crisis on our southern border this has
exploded into a conversation about free
speech the normal free speech warriors
are notably silent in their defense of
the protesters other than saying that
this isn't exactly the peaceful speech
that they defend and champion they're
saying some of them that listen this is
a restaurant and you're interrupting
someone's meal and that the restaurant
is free to handle this however they want
and the restaurant did handle it however
they wanted which was to allow this to
go on the protesters went on for a
minute after minute after minute and
they were not kicked out and that was a
decision that the restaurant was able to
make and you could say well this is rude
or it's disrespectful to Kristen Nielsen
but there's nothing about free speech
that says if someone's having enchiladas
you can't say whatever you want as long
as you're not physically a grieving that
individual and excuse me if I lack
empathy but I don't care that you
couldn't have a quiet dinner out she is
causing untold strife is complicit in
untold strife with this scale up of the
child
tournament camps and separations from
parents if your claim is she should be
shielded from uncomfortable speech when
she's hoping to have margaritas at M xdc
then I simply disagree with you I like
that this happened I like that the
restaurant didn't kick out the
protesters and let the protest go on for
many many minutes looked like free
speech at its best to me and I think she
has a secret service around her -
because she's a cabinet secretary of
some kind of security and so we don't
have to worry about her safety
necessarily or it looked like she was in
good hands at the very least there was
no physical risk to her whatsoever there
was no indication that the protesters
were getting physically violent and even
if they had she does have a cabinet or
whatever you would call DC Security
Secret Service I'm not exactly sure
which department it is I am again
reminded again because it happened to be
at not just a Mexican restaurant but a
restaurant in general about the late
Anthony Bourdain who pointed out many
times that there is a hypocrisy with
immigration where Latin American
immigrants disproportionately grow and
harvest a ton of the food that we eat
and then cook their fair share of it and
more at the restaurants that have
received the food that they have helped
to grow and harvest the entire service
economy of the United States would
collapse were it not for Latin American
immigrants both documented and
undocumented and we hear oh they're
stealing our jobs and they're dangerous
immigrants when it comes to the
restaurant industry they are
single-handedly keeping the industry
afloat and as far as Kristen Nielsen she
should resign I have no idea whether she
will but she should the pressure is on
her we've seen a lot of people who
should resign Scott Pruett still hasn't
resigned from the EPA
there's every indication she will stay
but she should resign and if you're
gonna be complicit in the detention of
children at least have the decency to
eat your dinner at home right yes just
stay home and defrost a pizza or
something